i'd really like to drink some alcohol
do you know where i can do that yes
[Music]
hello i'm jinx monsoon and i'm vandala
cram
and you may recognize us from the
upcoming film happiest
season but you probably won't because
we're not wearing any makeup yet
that's right we're um totally different
people right now you may not recognize
us from the upcoming film happiest
season but we're in it
we are once we look good it is an
amazing
holiday rom-com full of heartwarming
antics and hilarious
performances performances it's a lesbian
romance
and um peppered with all sorts of
huge queer celebrities such as
ourselves size 8 celebrities such as
ourselves
we are here today to show you how to get
your most glamorous
holiday looks or at least how to get our
most glamorous holiday looks
you're gonna watch step by step how we
transform ourselves from these naked
mole rats into glamorous female beings
oh my goodness of course you can't start
out
on a really glamorous holiday look
without um
the most glamorous drag ingredient of
all which is copious amounts
of eyebrow glue just slather it on
just really get it at sea gorgeous
already or if you want to avoid that
whole hornet's nest all together you
could just shave your eyebrows off
the thing is that by shaving your
eyebrows you really miss out on
the best step of this which is looking
like an oompa loompa
i start with makeup that um creates a
oil-based foundation for the rest of my
makeup
all right so now is the part where i
really get to
comb this this medical adhesive that i'm
using
all the way through every inch of my
coarse masculine eyebrow hairs
is that its original purpose is medical
adhesive yeah this is made to like
glue people back together after you
perform surgery on them a lot of drag
queens use glue sticks
but as jinx uh knows well let's just say
i'm a sweater i'm a holiday sweater
and this is the only thing
that i don't sweat off
you'll also notice that both of us do a
lot of finger painting
when we're getting into drag and there's
many um
makeup elitists who would say that that
is somehow
an inferior process when you find what
works why stray from it and
we just both really like to put our
palms fully down in grease paint and
smear it all the way wear it all over
next i have to paint a big
um dark line under my chin but not
so close to my actual chin that it
accentuates
um my my incoming my incoming jowls
thanks to my genetics and my age but i
do a
like you know a semicircle
under my chin to create the illusion
of a cut jawline so jinx do you
have any specific uh steps that you do
around the holidays to create a holiday
look
i um i would say that i lean more into
the holiday colors
um around this time of year so i do a
lot more gold eyeshadow it explains the
green undertones
if i'm wearing red i like to do a green
eyeshadow or vice versa if i'm wearing
green i like to wear a red eye shadow
and then
um gold highlights silver accents
i think the holidays is the i'm not one
of those queens who likes to wear
glitter on my face
but i will for the holidays if you're
looking to get in a festive mood while
you put on your makeup
you of course want to put on a festive
holiday soundtrack
uh as evidenced by the happiest season
soundtrack that you're hearing right now
so i did this to save time on a film set
with jayla i took this big piece of
plastic
then i used a sharpie to draw on my
ideal eyebrow then i used an x-acto
knife to cut
that eyebrow out and then what i do is i
take one of my makeup sponges
dip it in my um my contour cream
then i put the eyebrow where it needs to
go generally about where eyebrows
live on your face and then i can just in
the ballpark
in the ballpark and then i can just um
clock this on over it and then my
eyebrows right where i need it to be
without like spending um
20 minutes meticulously hand painting it
if anybody's wondering why i have this
um why i've put this driven
snow for the holiday of tying this into
the holidays on my um
on it's this is to this powder catches
all of the
um uh all of the various droppings and
fallings
of your holiday eye shadow look right so
important because if you
if you put down your foundation and you
accidentally sprinkle
some black or blue eyeshadow if it falls
off or shakes off of your eyelid while
you're doing your makeup and it gets on
your cheeks
and you've already done your foundation
there's no getting it off
it's like and even if you rub it out
even if you like put makeup over it it's
still there it's still visible
what i'm doing right now is known as
cutting a crease
which means that i am lying to the
viewer
by pretending that where my eyelid kind
of creases here is actually like a solid
half
inch above where it is that's really
again it's like we're trying to make
our actual skulls look smaller by just
making all of our um
features entirely too big oh my god i
seriously just looking at you in the
mirror
i thought you had some sort of i don't
even know what i thought was on you
you look insane i know i'm already
starting on my
liquid liner to create a nice cat eye
really
lift that this gives the illusion of my
um recently tottened face lift
tightened snatched snatched that's what
the drag queens say
so what i do i don't know how you can
see it is i've done like
um i did the lower part of my brow and
then the upper part of my brow and
i leave this little gap right here and
what i'm gonna then
do is take a little bit more of this
highlighter
and fill it in right in the middle right
there and then
i'm going to take the eyebrow brush i
already used with my eyebrow color on it
um brush off some of the excess and then
go over the highlighter
so it's the same color as my eyebrows
but it's a little lighter and i get this
ombre effect i do my lower eyeliner
in my liquid eyeliner as well i do like
sort of a straight
dropped line because see look how much
bigger my eyes look
because i drew this line down here and
then i blend that line again with my
angle brush which i just used for
everything
now that i've done my eyes i can brush
off this
um alaska calls them cook bars oh yeah
i'm going to get mine
off there too cook bars partially right
it's because they are a drop cloth like
we said to kind of catch
excess stuff i just wipe makeup tarp on
your face makeup tarp
now that my eyes are done this is what i
love about
the way that i do my foundation is that
i don't really have to do much for my
um facial contour you know i spent all
that time with
with alabaster and ultra beige
and medium tan i use rosewood it's a
very
light contour color for my pale pale
face and i just get it on my contour
brush
and then i can really lightly
you know just hit all the spots that i
already laid down
earlier in my foundation um phase i
think i forgot to shave my cheeks that's
a holiday makeup tip
because if you forget to shave just put
on some extra blush
i feel like part of a
wintry holiday look for me is really
about
rosy cheeks i really like to go for it
on the pink blushes
around the holiday season do i look like
kristen stewart
i feel like i do a little i feel like
this is what kristen stewart looks like
right yeah
all thin and beautiful so now it's time
for a classic holiday lip
so i always start with um with a
a nice true red lip liner pencil and
this one is discontinued this is a brand
that's discontinued
i had to hunt it down i like bought
every one that they had on like ebay and
etsy just like old ones that people had
avoided so now i have this
this true red pencil that you can't have
and i
over draw my lips by quite a bit i know
it's shocking i know it's shocking but
but i start with
my little bow here just above my eye and
i'll just
cheat it up cheetah up while she's doing
that i'll quickly let you know because i
have a fairly small eyes
i do not do eyeliner all the way to my
tear duct
i do from the outside corner just to the
center
and then i'm going to kind of faux line
my eyes later with my mascara
but i just kind of hit the outside
corner of my eye with my lower liner
and then my upper liner is a whole
different story me too i do that too
but you can see that i went like i go
real high with my lip line because i
have
thin little thin little lips in order to
make my eye really pop i
always do a really light color right in
the
tear area my my cry parts
i think it's called the tear line it's
called the tear line
um so i always do uh i always put like a
a little pop of highlight in my tear
line and then in this
space on the outside corner of my eye to
kind of open it up a little bit
look at that look at that pop i'm really
happy with my eyeliner today sometimes i
end up with eyeliner that's like
this thick because i don't get the lines
the way i want them to and i have to
keep going over it and over and it keeps
expanding every time
i've had that happen with eyeliner and
lips until you just have they're just
like
a full third of your face so now for me
it's time for the period on the sentence
of my face
which is my beauty mark my signature
beauty mark that goes right here
where my actual beauty mark is
that just looks like it's it because
it's covered in makeup
so jinx is upstairs um performing some
sort of
holiday witch drag magic on herself but
we have very different wig processes
so i'm going to show you mine and the
first thing you need to know
is that um no holiday look would be
complete without spray painting your
head black
so that's what i always start with
because i use my own natural hair in the
front
so see you just um all you do to
create this stunning flawless natural
hairline
is um just spray paint yourself
natural holiday look there you go and
then i'm going to take this
ratty holiday muffin and i'm going to
clip it to the top of my head
and then look at this gorgeous lady look
at this beautiful
lady right here this um abomination
on my head here is just to give a little
extra oomph just to give a little
a little volume i think jinx is putting
on
um some hit pads and some boobs and
stuff and
maybe i should do that because that's
part of holiday looks as well
so i'm gonna go do that magic where you
don't have to um
see my um my intimates then we'll be
back in
full force okay so after
hair and makeup we've chosen our festive
holiday
looks and of course so all you need to
do is uh find a friend and then the two
of you
find corresponding christmas ornament uh
fabrics and then have them specially
made it's simple as that one two three
so let's show off our finished holiday
looks sure
there you have it everyone truly a
little bit of holiday magic just wear
the silhouette that's most
flattering and suited to you and find a
festive holiday print
and there you go you're all ready for a
holiday
soiree with your blood family or chosen
family
i'm vandala cram and i'm jinx monsoo
and thanks so much for spending the
holidays watching us put our makeup on
and be sure to check out happiest season
featuring us
and a lot of other more famous people on
hulu
have a happy safe a socially distant
holiday everybody
wear your masks wash your hands
drink water that's just a general rule
[Music]
you